but what happens if you now erase
because some people want to just get rid
of Muslims so let's say they can have
their way and they go back in a time
machine what would happen if they erased
those Muslims that came up with those
concepts at that time what would happen
now and then we fast forward today yes
what would we lose it now I don't think
we'd have the eyes or heads anything
that what would happen let's take the
facts so Osman Empire was a Muslim
Muslim state giving the freedom to
everyone all the citizen right treating
them equal have Ottoman Empire not done
that how is it that possible for a
Muslim empire to stay in Balkan for 600
years but the Hitler as a Christian
couldn't stay six years it's like when
did you think that you had no purpose
are he worthless the value comes from
purpose assalamualaikum welcome back to
the D show and we have executive
director historian Halil Damir how are
you somali comb a little salon oh thank
you so much thank you for being with us
here on the d show I'm honored to be
here thank you thank you so we're here
in Ramadan and I'm very honored to have
someone with your expertise you've been
studying history now for how long I lost
the count of the years I hope for a very
long time so you are we can ask you or
anything regarding you know Islamic
civilization and that's something that
we get hit with a lot well let's start
with this the Prophet Ibrahim alayhi Sam
Abraham yes who Allah says in the Quran
he wasn't a Jew or a Christian but he
was one who submitted himself to the
Almighty to God and that's what a Muslim
is right if you were actually where was
he born he was born in city of Orpha
you're from there
I'm from her fire yeah tell us about
that
so aura is a very historical city such
eastern Turkey between between Syria and
Turkey very closer to rocky border as
you know ibraheem alehissalaam was born
according to torah in city of euro
Khaldun so Khaldun is the it is a
Mesopotamia and that is a promise of
Tamiya and ibraheem alehissalaam has has
has city of Harran that were ibrahim
alaih-is-salaam brothers the city named
after his brother
sohara still exists today yeah and ii
Crusaders when they were invading the
land of land of Muslims the first
Crusader went to Jerusalem but the
second Crusader went to her and went to
alpha the reason
oofah was very important for the for the
religious person web purpose and city
offer was seeing as a holy city you know
a very religious center so when we take
Abraham alayhis-salam Ibrahim alehsalaam
journey so according to torah ibrahim
alaih-is-salaam you should live in city
of or of Khaldun so some some assumption
by the late historians that he was in
city of o of Iraq and if he was living
in city of all of Iraq then Ibrahim Ali
Salim doesn't need to go all the way to
up in a very dangerous road and then
turn left go all the way to Saturn
Turkey and then leave there for very
long time and then go down to Palestine
rather he will cross the road go
directly from Iraq to Syria and and
Palestine so geographically that is
doesn't make sense
one two ibrahim alaih-is-salaam for for
people to be named the city named after
you you have to be living in that's the
very long time so Haram was named after
his his you know his older brother and
his father's terrorist grave is still in
Iran today you can you can visit now his
nephew searched died there and city of
search named after him all these are
there you know we can we can witness
also Ibrahim Ali
was thrown into fire in city of alpha
and the heart of alpha there is a lake
huge lake thousands and hundred
thousands of fishes in this lake so the
oral history tells us that ibraheem
alehissalaam when thrown into fire that
lake the fire become become water and
then branches become fishes and exists
today in Orpha you know when we visit
the city in heart of city and people
don't touch these fishes so we know from
the oral history that these fishes has
something to do with ibrahim
alaih-is-salaam definitely and they
don't call it this they change the name
of the city now right well this they
call Shandy or feh the Turkish modern
history reason is that the after first
world war or along with the Mirage and
resent at the border Syrian border was
occupied by France and the people of
Orpha revolted and then actually forced
the French and the occupation they do to
these heroic struggle of without
military the civilians the Turkish
government modern Turkish government
named Shanley means you know Andre yeah
we we often hear because as you know the
islamaphobe big industry is huge and and
one of the talking points that they like
to use a lot of times is they try to
make Muslims out to be like backwards
like they haven't contributed anything
to human civilization how true is that
point that's that's that's nonsense so
it's really nonsense first of all you
know the clash of civilization is
nonsense the civilization don't clash
civilization actually being a build over
each other
contributed collaborated and
strengthened the civilization is the the
belong the whole whole whole humanity so
what we should say sugar is coming from
the Chinese civilization so without
sugar we will have probably area of this
coffee tea even though we festive
problem but right now we wouldn't have
it maybe we won't have the diabetes in
all these states from China or the
copper's the paper is coming from the
civilization of the Egyptian
civilization so we saw that civilization
we wouldn't have paper or many many
medical things that we talked about
today all are coming from the Samaritan
civilization so Babylonian civilization
the Constitution that written
constitution coming from Babylonians
civilization so civilization there is no
clash of civilization that is
collaboration and building on each other
rather as civilization doesn't clash it
rather collaborate in that Islamic
Islamic civilization and contribution of
Islamic civilization undeniable so many
scholars in medieval times went and
studied in universities of har on
university of of Baja Damascus and learn
and when we look at in fact they were
philosopher you wouldn't believe it very
interesting but in Muslim Islamic
civilization the teaching was so liberal
was so open and in the mattresses in the
the universities they were a taste
actually denying that God exists
while discussing with the Muslim
scholars and they were still able to
study in these nice universities so
that's this civilization built and
supported and whatever the vessel
installation I mean in fact also all the
Greek civilization the Greek
philosophers were translated by the
Muslims and then translated from arabic
into european languages so europe
actually learned about the Greek
civilization and Greek philosophers
through the Muslims and their
translations and that is undeniable this
is very you know the very and knowledge
that every every learned man in Europe
knows that I like what you said ok so
because they try to put out their class
of civilizations so right from that
title you're separating yes sir you're
separating human beings but yours you're
saying right now it was a collaboration
so different civilizations they added
and from there others they added and now
we come to what we have today but what
are some of the top things that come to
your mind that the Muslim civilization
that day let's say the top three four or
five things that come to mind
people are still benefiting from today
oh it's very simple you know the your
chemistry the chemistry yes sir geometry
yes if someone says how how is that all
very simple when you know any any one if
have these this question very simple
look take any book history of science
study history of science is very very
clearly and go every history of science
book will have a section of Islamic
civilization you can look at it and you
will see what the contribution of the
Muslims are in the you know the
civilization of the build beyond that
let's go to the back if you so we
already covered one we got the math so I
you got chemistry
yes geometry so math yes sir D the
algebra is algebra yes it's coming
coming
the name algebra itself is coming mean
job in man hey on the name is coming
from you know the the the person who
actually created that so is this
historically substantiated that what
Muslims came up with these mathematics
concepts as I said just take one of
these these history of science book and
you will see there so what happens if
you now erase because some people want
to just get rid of Muslims so let's say
they can have their way and they go back
in a time machine what would happen if
they erased those Muslims that came up
with those concepts at that time what
would happen now and then we fast
forward today yes
what would we lose it now I don't think
we'd have the ISO heads anything that
what would happen you telling me
a world without Islam right now how
world with Islam well with just these
few things yes so we have to go little
back go back to history of the
monetarism so the monotectic culture the
monitor the monotheistic civilization as
I say it comes from city of Alpha is
emitted you know middle eastern Middle
Eastern thought so start with Iraq
Abraham al-islam or all three
monotheistic religion believe the
message the he brought you know the the
monotheistic thoughts right so look at
the civilizations in the world that
affected by these three religion so all
goes back to the monitor
stick civilization and that itself it's
coming from coming from Middle East
itself is is basically a culture is a
Middle Eastern culture where the Muslims
are Muslim are majority today so
therefore I'm denying
even when you deny everything but the
three books that the civilization
monotheistic civilization that brought
to mankind has changed the history of
mankind once and for all so you can't
deny one part of it you can deny by
other part of it but the civilization
monotectic civilization today's affected
whole world no one can deny that so
Islam is part of that monotheistic
monotheistic culture and Islam has been
you know shaping and contributing and
building last almost a thousand four
hundred years yeah
okay and brought brought so many changes
to the to the history of the mankind a
human being benefited from that and he
try to deny that Islam wouldn't exist
and a world without Islam first of all
wouldn't will that will not be possible
but even when you have a dream like that
itself you have to take big portion of
the whatever you call Christian
civilization and you have to throw into
into the lake or into the ocean to get
rid of the Islamic civilization because
undeniable has affected from the art art
the architecture everything else that
you can imagine undeniably is orient
origin give us please a couple more so
we cover geometry the math the algebra
what are the couple things country okay
take history so history and sociology
developed by by eben hall do so until
evening hold on we have history and
someone never heard this name who is who
is he okay evening Holden is historian
and philosopher and he was born in under
loose and then he moved to read Spain
now I Spain today Spain he was bored
then born there and then he moved
and later he become Kobe in Egypt and he
died in Egypt he became a judge in Egypt
he was yes iCarly he was a top judge
actually and he was a statement he was a
statement he was you know as a diplomat
he was sent to meet the timer when he
was coming to over the cover the cover
the land of the Turks I mean let Ottoman
Empire in Anatolia he met them and in
fact timer has invited him to come come
with him so he until we reach evening
hold on we have all the chronology so
we'll write says in this year this king
that the debt and this until him in hold
on even hold on comes he says this is
not history and we have to we have to
look at before and after we have to look
at every aspect of true and reasons why
this happen in order for us to
understand and maybe not repeat if we're
going to repeat think twice before
before we makes a mistake
so that become history same thing
sociology until evening all noon was the
first one ever thought he that every
interaction human interaction follows a
pattern so he his famous circle theory
circle theory says then the civilization
will come will go up will reach pick
will slowly go down and then he explains
every stage of at one and how while he
explained all these stages he told also
human interaction and reason so there is
a pattern that he says that human being
follows and that was later on recognized
as a sociology so until August calm calm
within the world sociology there was
actually not known to anyone but even in
all doom
so we linked that that's the root of it
and we use it today George buzzer so now
if you didn't have him you wouldn't have
that know today well you will not have
that sociology today what we understand
nor we will have a history as it is as a
his
as what behavior today because it
history would be only like Herodotus
history only Cremona and all I can see
is a lazy argument like someone who says
well if it wasn't him it would have been
someone else I mean that someone else
would have developed it maybe sometime
later but that's just like lazy argument
okay well you know if we go maybe maybe
them we will don't have as well as a
yeah so you know before him nobody
talked about it before him and then
nobody and he thought so the fact is
he's the one so the fact is he's the one
and we have it today and that is based
on his thumb attached that he started
that's a specialization la mesa verde he
was and his famous book called
introduction mock edema yeah is taught
in every University every you know the
humanities everybody every anyone who
study in European humanities they will
learn in columns so this is some more
evidence I like which said no class of
civilizations but what is the it's it's
as a collaboration aberration of the
civilizations all right but someone says
look give me one more now let's so we
had to give me another so we had here we
had the algebra geometry we had the
maths and now we have the history
sociology what else can the mind let's
go also the you know the medicine so
medicine that's a big one yes sir so it
is in us even is in us Shiva was later
the name again
even a B even cena even cena yes I think
it was translated as a vagina I think in
European language Anna right so he's his
book called Shiva now where's he from
who is he he he was born and you know
raised in today's modern Iran and he was
in fact he was a Turkish Turkish
speaking person or born in a Turkish
family and he liked science he has
studied medicine in early early age and
he becomes so professional he was the
first one actually started to operating
the human being so the operation
or precise operation identify and also
the the tools for the operation even
today when you look at again I refer to
history of science book you can see the
tools that he actually used was used in
Europe for very long time until the
modern times actually so he played a
very serious role in our modern medicine
actually so even Cena is very famous and
we have therapy for every philosopher
Farabee is also again a Turkish speaking
philosopher what specifics in medicine
now that people can link to even Cena
the operations the are excised
operations yes what is their operation
how do
yes note before when when you have you
have a stomach pain right so the
Egyptian operation usually will open
almost everything and go through so it
was even escena to identify very very
precise where is it actually and why and
where has to be operated it was his he's
told to rather than opening the whole
body
he was will always target certain area
and they used the tools that was not
used before so he created some tubes
actually himself now the tools on top or
operating towards medical tool and he
was the one who created these tools
actually for the operation so he's got
the patent on them if they had a patent
such thing if we had a way it's his
patent do people do the people today in
the Western world people who are
historian and we're not a horse that's
not something because there's a lot of
hidden history right yes and and why do
you think that a lot of these things
taught in this universities today of
this Islamic civilization how it's
contributed do you do see see a lot of
the stuff hidden and people don't you
know the average American doesn't get
this type of history
I thought you gotta go digging for it in
United States people usually don't read
or read you know but but European most
most educated Europeans will know all
these things when we talk about it so
that therefore when I I speak at a crowd
I don't need to explain who evening Hall
Doom was
or who even seen eyes because a
assumption is that most of the people
will know these names if you are
educated person in Europe definitely you
will know this name especially
humanities 100% you won't know what one
thing the environment now Andaluz Spain
where you had many was it the Jews who
fled persecution you had Christians and
you had dialog you had talk about the
atmosphere it was probably you know
according to historian probably one of
the best collaboration of the
civilization the science and art and
knowledge was used by everyone spread
and the religious communities will
collaborate will learn from each other
and today's you know hate was not there
was some respect and love so you had a
true sense of freedom of yeah if you're
a jeweler to practice Judaism Christian
to practice Christianity there was no by
the sword like no convert or die not at
all this is historic in historical fact
until what now the Inquisition yes until
the the Muslim were expelled from Spain
the the Catholic the Catholics took over
Spain and everything changed they start
with the with the the Muslims and Jew
like famous famous Jew communities they
the word the famous word among the among
the Jews called combat dos so they were
forced to convert or die healed yes so
what they tried to go ahead and put on
the Muslims which is something that
obviously because Islam means submission
to the will of God sincerely you can't
do it sincerely if it's done by the
sword right but they were doing it by
the sword but it stomach civilization
that is there is the order of God that
order says lot you could have like Rafa
Dean so that is the euro Islamic
civilization no compulsion no compulsion
no compulsion you can deny that were
they compelling people with these
Inquisition was gently yes this is known
historically yes and that's why you have
a Jewish community to the in Turkey a
big Jewish community
okay so this Jewish community the one
that expelled from Spain or run from
Spain they came and the Ottoman Empire
accepted them as refugees and they they
lived among the Muslims all these
centuries in fact there is one you know
when you're in Islam or you can visit
some of these very old churches I'm
sorry synagogues very old synagogues and
the community interestingly the Jewish
community in Istanbul still speak a
broken Spanish yeah still all the way to
today and they have a they have a niche
paper you know very long time and called
Shalom it's also you know used to be
half Spanish all the way all these
hundreds of years so the community that
came from Spain lived among the Muslims
all the way to today and they're still
they're part of our communities I don't
think ever any Jew has felt probably
threatened or disrespected just because
they they are Jew one name comes to mind
with the Moses this the Jewish scholar
Moses Maimonides yes yes tell us a lot
about him well you know he's not only
one in fact they're there when you look
at the Jewish history you will see a lot
of them and some of them actually named
later on because their names so some saw
Arabic names you wouldn't know that they
were there they were like they were like
a Jew scholars but the Jewish scholar
where they were because they were part
of society so was not like you know when
you have these books that you
specifically go and say these words
written by do but a lot of history books
especially for the strength Christianity
I have a lot of books are coming up
written by the by the great Jewish
scholars very respectful scholars
including Maimonides and they were
respected in Muslim Muslim land as being
part of to again part of Islamic
civilization because they were seasoned
they were part of the part of the
society they were never differentiated
like you are you are different or you're
something like a legal alien no you know
like we have that title likes our legal
alien you know
a second heat so I reason I mentioned
him because he was to this day he's
known as one of the greatest you know
Jewish Orthodox scholars isn't he they
look back to him so he was part of that
civilization he flourished in the Muslim
lands and many of them I I you know it's
many of them in fact it's very I bring
this up don't lose your point because
again you see a lot of the slum phone
industry they try to make it seem like
you know Muslims they hate Jews if they
had their way they'd kill everybody the
heads would be coming you got guys out
there who go in front of mosque and they
put a line over there their shirt and
they're you know trying to spread the
message like you know these Muslims are
barbarians they had it their way they'd
be chopping heads off right that's this
is not happening when we had early
history the Ottoman Empire had you know
a big portion of the you know Balkan was
under Ottoman Empire for I'm in for five
hundred years right so let's let's take
the facts so Osman Empire was a Muslim
Muslim state giving the freedom to
everyone all the citizen right treating
them equal have Ottoman Empire not done
that how is it that possible for a
Muslim empire to stay in Balkan for 600
years but the Hitler as a Christian
couldn't stay six years say that again
Hitler and Nazi Germany occupied the
same land where the Ottoman Empire so
today he was like he couldn't stay there
he couldn't he couldn't stay there he
couldn't hold it down six years they
held it down how long he six hundred
years so if you take a strong point Wow
logically it was an oppression it was I
feel you know you cannot keep people
under the fear have that made possible
Hitler will probably still still occupy
the whole whole Europe he couldn't hold
it down Hitler couldn't hold it down for
sixty they held it down for 600 yes sir
so how is it possible right yes II know
the Ottoman Empire in fact you know like
Yugoslavia Serbia it was a good example
we can proof
historically they collected taxes $0.50
but they they
invested $1 in fact so they know they
did not exploit anything what they going
to explode they're going to explode
watermelon Serbia a lot of watermelons
oh you two speaking of that tell us
we're there because again human beings
we can't expect human beings they're
perfectly imperfect so human being Islam
is perfect it's a sister from the
Creator but have there been sides times
in history where Muslims have made great
blunders and they've done because you
have a lot of complaints from Serbs they
talk about you know certain events that
happen oppression against them is there
something that we can say yeah okay they
made a mistake here is there something
like that you know I wouldn't take that
that part only but here is the fact we
have to ask also our serving friends so
why did Muslims come to Europe or Balkan
to start with so aggression against the
Christian it was so harsh the Christian
the father-in-law of thoughts Mumbai or
ham Bay I'm sorry
he recluse the king of Rome or the
Bisons ask Orhan Bay to come and defend
Christians from the fear of the Serbs
attack so the mean the Muslims came not
because they were you know they they
invaded they were invited by the
Christians by the Rome to defend them
against the aggression of the Serbs and
it's very easily you know you look at
the history and and you can see when the
the you know the Muslims moved over
Europe long before they conquered
Istanbul actually they conquered half of
the trachea and the reason is that
because they were defending Christian
minorities and the the Catholic
Christian minority in in Croatia will
witness and there are enough science you
know the the degree of the mohammed ii
Fatih Sultan Muhammad they decree that
he he give it to to the the Catholics is
proof it says literally you can find out
the you know the historical historical
document he says you have same rights
and any other season
listen of this country your school's
your ministries and you land belong to
you you will be treated with respect and
fair as anyone else ever you are
bothered if there you are for any reason
attacked my door is open to you saying
this now this is the head of the state
the president so this is he saying that
today the servant restriction anybody
minorities yes yeah tell us when we look
back in this area of the Balkans you
have the Bosnians who ended up becoming
Muslim how did that happen well the
Bosnian probably you know you have been
a Bosnian you know that Bosnians were
always they never accepted Christianity
in fact you know David Lee they were
monetized P they didn't accept the
Trinity
they never accept that they just pure
mono exactly they were monetized anyway
so when the the message of Islam came to
them was very simple message say you
know there is one God and one God alone
what message resonate it already
resonated with their belief because that
was they believed I was already what
were they called before Bosnians was it
BOGO meals or something like that you
know what i think i think that was says
I don't recall very well but I think
they have they were a minority but known
because they were like a montanus people
usually yeah the mantles people and the
freedom-loving people and no one could
actually control them due to you know
knowing knowing these very well so they
couldn't impose any anything on them so
when when islam came actually their
interaction with islam they find out you
know so this is my lifestyle anyway
that's why was he easy for for most in
fact that's what happens even with serbs
with Krotz in that area who are sincere
and they really generally want to
connect with the crater alone you know
who want to do what God wants them to do
that pure monotheism Islam connects it
goes what we call the fit through the
natural way worship the Creator not the
creation without so we see so many
people accepting Islam but if someone
says if they say well then why okay
great civilization great stories unity
but why all this dismay and destruction
when you look at
Afghanistan Iraq Somalia why is this
part of the Muslim world upside down and
in such misery see you know when we take
from the from the sociological
perspective remember the first world war
happened in Europe second world war
happen in Europe thirty years war
happened
the new religious wars happen in Europe
and millions of people wasted so for
very long time right so and when we look
at the the democracy development of the
democracy the French Revolution 1789
so between 1789 and 1945 and in the
Second World War you have millions of
people killed on soul of Europe
never-ending Wars never-ending Wars so
when you compare all these wars in in in
Muslim land will not probably make the
number what the the number of victims
during first world or Second World War
in Europe so 1945 after the Europeans
understood that the you know it's not a
solution always fighting each other and
you know Misaki Nene killing and you
have you know beginning of the European
Union so start talking and column that's
what we talk about you know not clash of
civilization collaboration of
civilization and we see in Europe so
french-speaking people and your German
circuit is speaking people really they
are different people
in every sense almost like culturally
and so but yet after seeing Second World
War you know so much destruction it's
not a solution for Europe and not for
mankind the other than collaboration and
working together that's how when
European Union start among the European
intellectuals so let's go back to the
Muslim land some of these Muslim
countries as you know they are very new
some of countries like Bahrain I think
nineteen eighty eighty to just become
independent so a most of the countries
they gain their independence in 1960s
that's our lifetime so between 1960s and
you know 2000 you have a 50 60 years of
period so in that is you know 50 60
years of period also you have the the
the foreign powers that always interfere
and invaded the land to create even more
misery well let's take Afghanistan
Afghanistan was a peaceful country until
1979 invasion of Soviet Union supporting
the Communist Party so you brought the
Communist Party on top of country a
Muslim very traditional and warrior
nation so then you have a war so that
invasion all the way to today
Afghanistan never had a peace but due to
an invasion a foreign invasion same
things apply almost everywhere the Jew
and Christian and Muslims live in
Palestine aside
five six hundred years together during
Ottoman Empire the Jewish community was
a part of the part of the civilization
they have very important roles to play
in fact III since I a lot of this
outside infamy interference making all
of these these problems known one other
things that you know historically so
Ottoman Empire as a Sunni dominating
country it has control of Iraq over six
hundred years right
so the Shia of Iraq lived there so there
were no single revolt of Shias during
the Sony domination the alavés in in
Syria lived there the Christian marinids
and phalanges in Lebanon lived there the
cups
lived you know Celtic Christian Coptic I
lived in in Egypt so these there is no
single revolt of these minorities of
fight between each other until the
modern maps are created nation divided
and hatred hatred build and we have all
these issues now has said you know the
Shia's and Sunnis are
are Muslims and leave together for under
Ottoman Empire for 600 years
no single Shia revolt against against
the Sunnis none so the same things apply
with the Christian minorities there is
no single revolt of the of the of the am
a Coptic Christian in in Egypt in fact
they were in ruling class most of you
know these learned people look at look
at the history books all history history
of Islam always written by Christian
scholars the Arab Christian scholars
they wrote let's take the the bath party
but party was you know Arab nationalism
most born during 1960s and the founder
of the Baath Party is a Christian
mashaallah flock it was a Christian Arab
so he was a nationalist Arab and he when
he was talking about Islam he was like
you know proudly talking about Islam
even though himself was a Christian or
let his dark as historic as is a foreign
minister of Iraq in in 80s and 90s
Tarkas is a Christian called anak
Christian but you will never know that
he was Christian because it was part of
a in Islamic civilization they were not
so much differentiating between being a
Christian Muslim or or Jew basically
what you can contribute society was more
important every every community played
role so some of this problem
unfortunately imposed on the Muslim
societies as in example in Afghanistan
okay so can you can you summarize is
this a quick summary if it's accurate
for someone because again when you're
blown back into the Stone Age
you're invaded your resources are
plundered colonization all of these are
the factors that we have what we have
today over there yes sir outside
interference how accurate is this film
they have this become very popular here
in America Arturo a total resurrection
yes yes resurrection yes Arturo in that
film
they actually have you seen it yes sir
they spent a lot of time showing the
enemies who are always plotting and
planning to
this dissension yes is that can weed if
it was happening then that's the story
correct you can just copy and paste same
thing happening today kind of well oh
yes well probably almost I you get what
I'm saying yes yes point so first of all
let us see the film the film is one of
the most watched in fact most watched
movie in the world translated almost in
every language side so it says carries
the values so if you are Christian Hindu
or Muslim doesn't make difference
actually the people watching the movie
movie transferring values telling you
being honest and decent and religious
are you sparrows values again honesty
yes virtue justice yes
you carry only fair energy so that's why
so a Christian identify and I I'm
witness at Christians identify
themselves with these these values
especially you know when you are a fair
person so I think movie from that
perspective show in it as you know is a
affection so has a lot of historical
fact and some you know stories to make
the make the entertainment is it to
watch but a lot of historical facts are
there and you can also see that
collaborating between the Christian and
the Muslims you can see also
collaborating with the with the you know
the Jewish communities and their place
in the Muslim society and and
contribution but basically carries the
values and these values were the
monotectic values and always shared by
every religious or spiritual person not
always hatred not always war not always
the vision not always they were known we
grow up in a multicultural society
Muslims communities were always
multicultural so there were no
differences between and the movie
teaches you there is no differences
between uncle Misha or uncle Mustapha as
long as you know they hold themselves to
these these values that make a good
human being and I think that's where
we're moving make a sense we're almost
out of time so the move
very accurate historically if someone
also wants to know about the Ottoman
Empire the rise of it Arturo he's the
father of Thoth Mamba he's the father
Aslan baits mom Bay is the FOB a what is
baby that's a pyramid a respect ya
mister sir Sir the high level respect
yes so you have a dude oh he's the
father father may Osman Bey is the
father of the Orhan Bay and or hanbei
father of the Mohammed jellybean father
I'm a television host Murad is the
father of the ad and goes on so that's
it that's the start from there and then
you can see historically how things
develop but one thing that people can
capture from there is our deep devotion
to God to the 1-yard to the Creator to
pure monotheism and that's what people
love about Islam is the pure monotheism
connecting with the Creator worshiping
the Creator alone not his creation and
those values you expose or virtue
honesty justice establishing peace and
respect for a woman any respect for a
woman it was there's very good so you
see the role of high mana right the
mother the motherly figure
Wow high mana right she is she's doesn't
look like the you know they have a
fantasy picture of the Muslim woman in
the mind of many people but you can see
high mana very active she's a clan
leader her decisions are decision her
leadership is respected by the Warriors
and also by the other clans right and
that was the Muslim role of a Muslim
woman totally different than the picture
that today actually shown to the world
you have some we're about at a time
tell us in his last couple of minutes we
have you were having some for turkey
some contest that was like at foundation
is you you probably can see the cat dot
orc as our website we have a contest
that we're going to take two guests to
Turkey and they can they will visit some
of these historical places that I
mentioned including ibrahim
alaih-is-salaam over you know place of
the Abraham and others also I don't know
you know we said they did not have
native the first church that was built
by the Powell's the Powell is also in
Turkey actually
in in Hapai so when these these these
gas comes they will visit the cat
foundation projects also they will spend
time to view the historical historical
places in Turkey in Istanbul and also
southeastern Turkey last piece of advice
for the not-yet Muslim who was out there
because everyone has the potential to
submit to the Creator and they're
listening and they've been just
bombarded with a lot of things on Fox
News a lot of the Islamic Obon industry
and now the history that they're getting
is just corrupted it's something you
know like we said you know the class of
civilizations they try to pump this up
what advice do you have for them that
are out there that they've been they've
been bombarded with all of this
distortion mistruths
what advice do you give for them you
being a historian you laugh at a lot of
these things that I mentioned III will
suggest special especially younger
brothers and sisters so learn your own
history and learn history of others and
you will see that you know the history
will teach you a lot and be proud of who
you are when you learn you will see how
great man and woman the history has has
created and be proud of who you are and
just live as a good Muslim and that
should be enough people will learn from
you just be you know the values that you
talk about carry these values and then
let let be it insha Allah and God God is
great hello I'm on it
yes please subscribe to the DCO follow
us on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]